To plot 5,115, we start with the horizontal coordinate. Beginning at 0, we count
to the right 5. And then, we deal with the vertical coordinate. From there, we
count up 115. And that brings us to this point. But from bringing back our
graph, we can see another way that we could have figured this out. By looking at
the line that we drew for the entire equation. Remember that on our table, we
saw 5 and 115 as a pair of values for d and n that belong together. Since it was
from that table that we developed our equation, and from our equation that we
got to this graph, it makes sense the graph would fit the table. What's really
cool about our line, though, is that our table only had the points that are
highlighted here in orange. Those are all the data we were given. But now, with
this whole line, we can start to make some extrapolation about data later on.